I've seen you before haven't I Oh Gary
right Barry Barry Allen sorry no it's
fine sorry yeah that reminds me who the
hell is this I created a whole other
existence there's even a flash so I
don't have to be like flash I'm gonna
help you suck the rival you just
kidnapped this one no I didn't she's a
scientist we need her oh honey the flash
isn't following listen john rowley
he's the flash
what's happening to me decidedly your
original life will fade away you won't
even remember that you're the flash a
little blinking
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie new flash
trailer so let's break it down
Gary Allen greatest flash of the
multiverse I love how they have fun with
it at the beginning oh my god it's Gary
Allen and you're the flash really the
big thing with this trailer in addition
to just having some fun with the
characters and getting our first like
real good look in dialog teaser from the
rival is showing you how Barry starts to
forget about his previous life meaning
he forgets about all the adventures he
had he forgets about the powers so he
forgets that he is the flash now
depending on how strictly they stick to
their time-travel rules there's a
difference between forgetting you're the
flash in time travel completely erasing
all potential of the Speed Force in your
body so we'll see how they explain it
when we get to the episode but I'll be
interested to see if after flashpoint he
remembers all the things that he is
forgetting in these first couple of
episodes because we actually learned
episode 2 is another flashpoint episode
where Barry starts to realize more fully
the consequences of what he's done so it
sounds like a lot of the really fun
stuff that's happening here like where
he goes in steals caitlin from mercury
labs oh we need her she's a scientist
that covers like the early part of the
episode and then probably towards the
end when they're facing the rivals when
he starts to forget his powers and then
we get to this moment with eobard thawne
and that kind of leads into the next
episode like you will totally forget
that you're the flash the thing that
they haven't included in any of these
trailers is the reverse-flash saying the
same thing about himself because if
Barry's subject to flashpoint
consequences wouldn't that also
butterfly effect hurt eobard thawne in
the future so I'll be interested to see
how they explained the rival we'll
probably learn a little bit about his
characters through Wally because Barry
just came through the whole zoom ordeal
in season two so he's riding pretty high
like okay we got this we can totally
defeat him there's two of us now but
then yeah flashpoint so I'll be
interested to see like where we're at
after he fixes flashpoint I wouldn't
expect them to explain too much stuff
before they fix it because usually they
hold off to like really big reveals on
villains till like the mid-season finale
or even like the back half of the season
speaking of which we learned that Tom
Felton's character Julian Doran who's
like a made-up name I think he's going
to be dr. alchemy we meet him in the
second episode
the berry is just like amazed to learn
that he doesn't like him the first time
he meets him but I probably don't have
to tell you that even though we meet tom
felton before flashpoint gets fixed of
course he's going to be a big character
after flashpoint so I'll be interested
to see how they play with dr. Alchemy's
character because he sounds more like
the second version of the character the
one that Jeff Jones created who worked
inside the crime lab with Barry but we
see this person in the mask and
supposedly Tobin Bell is voicing dr.
alchemy zooms style like Tony Todd did
the voice for zoom like the you know
really scary scratchy voice so we'll see
what's going on with that in the second
episode and that's also probably when
Tom Cavanaugh and Jesse quick come back
because there's already so much ground
for the episode to cover like you have
to explain what Barry's been doing in
this whole time during the summer break
you have to explain all the flashpoint
changes he has to react to those they
have to have a little bit of fun
learning about the second version the
flash Kid Flash don't call me that man
the new evil speedster the rival Savitt
are and then they can introduce like all
the other characters it's kind of the
same thing with the other comic book
shows like you introduced this big new
flashy thing like Ghost Rider
in the first episode then the second
episode you introduced everybody else so
it's gonna be awesome I don't know if
we're gonna get any more trailers before
the season drops maybe a little bit next
week just because it's the week before
all the big premieres so they're gonna
want to hype it up as much as possible
but just a heads up that first week in
October when flash comes back only flash
and arrow are premiering the week after
that is when Supergirl and legends of
tomorrow just a society premiere so if
you're not sure when stuff is coming
back and you're worried about missing it
just be sure you know want to subscribe
to get all my videos but make sure when
you subscribe to enable upload alerts
even though like the general YouTube
experience is a lot more fun on desktop
than it is on mobile but you know mobile
phones can be really helpful for like
reminding you like oh there's a new
video there's new flash and I haven't
quite figured out what the schedule with
like Supergirl Gotham and like legends
of tomorrow videos are gonna be it just
depends on how good the seasons are but
I'm hoping they're way better so
hopefully they'll be videos for every
single episode but we'll just see when
they drop the first episode I know
supergirls gonna be a lot better but a
lot of times you just have to wait to
actually see it so I've already done a
couple other videos about the rest of
the season on the flash like I did a
video about the killer frost episode
they're gonna be doing Kevin Smith's
still filming that right now like he
posted this picture of him with his
giant slate because they're spending all
day inside the cortex meaning that they
might have somebody locked up and they
just having a lot of scenes talking to
them or that's the episode where they
turned Kaitlyn into killer frost it's
just that you don't spend a lot of time
in the cortex unless something really
dramatic or really hardcore is happening
so they are wasting no time the first
half of the season in doing really
really big things and this is all
building up to the four night crossover
speaking of which I'll put a link to it
at the end of this but arrow just teased
its hundredth episode that's also
happening during the four night
crossover Robert Queen is back Katie
Cassidy is back as Laurel so either
they're traveling back into the past via
time travel or it's gonna be earth to
Robert Queen who became the green arrow
on that show in black siren so both the
flash and arrow are gonna start filming
that crossover episode really soon so
we'll probably be getting more teasers
from behind the scenes for that so
whatever ends up happening I'll totally
do videos for it but congratulations to
this week's flash giveaway winner fast
quiver you want a copy of the season 2
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details so I think
a lot of the YouTube bugs that people
have been having the last couple of days
are mostly gone but if you're still
having problems clicking on the links
that I put at the end of videos on your
mobile phones or on desktop just let me
know and let me know like which browser
you're using when you're having problems
but everything should be fine by the
time we start the season I do post
updates on like when videos are gonna
post and like if there is like some
problem usually I'm posting on Twitter
these are the links for that so if you
guys want you can follow me there too
for updates during the day I'm like when
videos are gonna post but it's gonna be
awesome it's gonna be a really good
season I feel like everybody you like
creatively like everything's just gotten
like a little bit better well you guys
wait for that next video to post you can
click here for the arrow 100
episode teaser you can click here for
the Supergirl season 2 Superman trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight